How much mk4 should be taken to combat further calcifications?
Well mk4 doesn't combat calcifications
So mk4 is a form of vitamin K that you use with calcium to get calcium into the bone
But maybe what you're asking is if I tend to be a bone former
Like I don't handle my calcium well, well, would taking just straight mk4
I'll get the calcium out of the tissues and help it in bone
that's
Maybe a better question and I
Formated in that way because I don't know the answer to it
Rettling and I know I think that would be an experiment that I have to look that up and search whether it would
Somebody who is a bone former should they be taking should they could they be taking mk4 to help combat tissue?
Laydown of calcium good question. Oh, I know that
Just some research on them. So I haven't had anybody ask me questions about being bone former since my days and taking plane film x raise
On people back in the 80s. So I'll do a little bit of research on that